in some 21 months when you combine the
double whammy of inflation and the war
in ukraine what can people expect in
terms of nuts and bolts with the market
over the next weeks and months
well when you when you look at what
we've had in 2022 it's been real
challenging for investors right we
started out covet 19 still concerned
about spike and that
we then talked about inflation the fed
raising interest rates and then we were
hit with the russian ukraine
conflict what the first thing that we
always look at is how diversified and
right now
investors understand if they're
diversified or not right what kind of
impact do they have do they have
different asset styles in their
portfolio great example asset styles
would be
value versus growth values down as of
friday was down about five percent where
growth is down about 15 percent
so you really can start to look at a
lack of diversification in the portfolio
and that's probably the first thing you
should do to improve for the upcoming
market experts like yourself look at
every scenario if there is a situation
where china invades taiwan or if russia
went somehow into a nato country that's
going to increase volatility but if that
doesn't happen if the conflict stays
within ukraine if there are brighter
days ahead there
what can we expect in terms of recovery
we have we have seen today the united
states may weather this a little better
than expected yeah i think that the
recovery starts with the diversification
right how deep of a whole are you in uh
the second part is selecting certain
sectors that you expect to do well
whether that is the financial sector
where rates rising those tend to do well
uh banks in in
in in that sector you can also look at
possibly adding energy stocks right we
even even though energy stocks have had
a huge run up talk about a negative
market energy stocks are up 22 this year
uh so so you can still put some of that
in the portfolio that will allow you to
participate with the upside still have
some some downside protection looking at
energy
defense technology some of the things
that could go up what about the person
watching just going wait a second a lot
of cyber warfare with russia what if
they hit our banks hypothetically how
much cash should i have on hand what do
you recommend people to just have a
little more money aside
yeah i think before diversification you
have to look at what type of planning
you put in your portfolio so what a lot
of what we do is we look at three
segments of a portfolio and we put those
into those different segments or three
buckets if you will the first is the
liquidity bucket for individual that is
retired perhaps that's a year's worth of
income that's in that budget is that
right perhaps there's you you know that
you want to buy a house so that's in
that bucket so emotionally that's a much
better conversation to have with your
advisor with yourself that you have a
year's worth of spending and you don't
have to worry about those ups and downs
in the market day-to-day we have to wrap
here but a very quick answer on this how
much will the covid recovery that's
already happened the fact that we're
coming down so much from omicron how
much will that help moving forward
economically
it's it's going to be a big help it's
going to be a big help with inflation as
the spin the dollars that we spend as
consumers goes away from goods and into
service and hopefully vegas will uh
participate in that and have a lot more
good upcoming months okay those tourists
are coming back we appreciate your
expertise thank you so much russell
price with
ubs